PROFESSOR: This is Mathematics
for Computer Science,
6.042J/18.062J, a joint subject
between electrical engineering
and computer science
and mathematics.
Welcome.
The instructors are
Professor Adam Chlipala
and Professor Albert R. Meyer.
And I'm Albert.
Hi, ya.
Quickly summarizing what
this course is about,
it's about the math that
computer scientists almost all
need regularly and
which you're not
likely to have come across in
your standard calculus classes.
You may have seen some of
this stuff in high school.
For example, in
calculus courses people
talk about functions
on the real numbers.
And sometimes, they'll
talk about functions
on the complex numbers.
But computer
scientists are usually
dealing with much more abstract
functions on data types
and even functions on functions.
And I wonder how many of you, if
I ask you to define abstractly
what a function was, could
give that definition.
In a couple of
weeks in this class,
you'll be able to do
that with facility.
We will also be
talking about a variety
of standard discrete structures,
starting with the numbers which
we think of as a
structure, because it's
the numbers packaged with
the operations on them,
like plus and times
and exponentiation.
We'll also talk about various
other standard data structures,
like graphs and trees.
And we'll look at
methods for counting
the numbers of these different
kinds of data structures,
as a typical fundamental problem
in computer science, where
you typically want to know
how big is the search space.
For example, the search space
of passwords had better be large
or a cracker can just
search through them
all to find one that works.
And finally, we'll talk about
discrete probability theory,
which is simply a version
of probability theory,
where we can get by
with sums instead
of getting into the
complications of integrals.
So here's a quick sanity
check, or vocabulary check.
Do you know what discrete means?
And I'll give you a hint.
It doesn't mean discreet.
If you don't know, this is a
good moment to stop the video
and look it up.